[Music]
and sleazy comp news Wow submitted by
joe is a lyrical genius who give him
some flow right now listen to me flow my
name is Joe why oh that [ __ ] was [ __ ]
bar side you fear me bars larceny family
bars
I got bars like a star close oh [ __ ]
Bobby don't you know don't give it all
away
an officer offered to fix a team's
traffic ticket but only if she sent him
nude I would do that intersection I
never had not your nudes
I wanted but I liked the opportunity I
would I would do as far as I got was the
guy's pulled me over we're going to give
me a ticket in the middle of writing
ticket starts flirting with me still
give me the ticket I'm like doctors you
didn't give him your number
you know what every time I speed and get
a ticket all I got to do is show my dick
do it in a heartbeat me to the girls the
girls don't want that ball right come on
lat they I don't think a girl would ever
ask okay I'm not going to give you a
ticket mister person a guy with a dick
all you got to do is show me the tip I
don't think a girl never saw it mean
that flaccid dick isn't attractive yes
it is I could send her a snapchat dick
or a snapper dick
would you girls if a cop was gonna write
you up a ticket and then they're like
show me a tea no are you absolutely all
three of you I'll serve you snapchat or
in real life you're like just pop it on
real glass too personal what you guys
love ticket what he answered for us well
hon so what kind of ticket like beatings
are you going like 129 on my record 140
miles per hour and a 65 mile per hour
and you're spending $400 oh honey there
any my six cleaning ticket yep it's
going to make your insurance hi it's
just one second one second it's gonna
make your insurance high you go haha
like that you have a body can no you
can't save the egg
hey if I'm desperate enough like if I
can't pay for a ticket and I'm just like
I think you can't be able to take it
I still got a record increase your
insurance so it's like a monthly
increase now I don't want anything I'll
just do the traffic school
whoa this is ticket saying I'd rather
show a dick than to go to eight hours of
time I know but that's why nobody wants
you you're too easy that's what I want
all of us I'll show my butthole oh yes I
don't know that's any better bro Dean is
more rare I've seen it how do you even
send a butthole picture the father get
the right angle you know what the funny
thing is you either set the timer and
then you have to have a phone like this
feather sticks you know the stick foam
yeah BAM and it's at the time I actually
don't know my butt looks like I'm gonna
take a piss on my please do not because
I feel like what you have pictures of
that you're gonna sit at home looks like
though have you seen Brady's bottle yes
okay then that's it
my mouth Peter I don't think like that I
mean it's close enough just imagine this
color on your ass that's it you know
your butthole yes of course how how do
you know what the clapping I have a
mirror I've been looking at it not
recently but I was very curious I wanted
to see what all of that looked like
almost like a fish on my bubble girl a
girl watching what's a vagina looks like
and in confession that you just see the
butthole - because I have no idea my
father looks like well that's usually
done with throw off the bus in it I go
you know I would crack the [ __ ] up right
let's send you to our home you get to
leave them home for a few minutes right
right
he goes into the bathroom and then you
realize you forgot your chapstick and
you going to you know what no and they
wouldn't have been like that what you
wouldn't be surprised he would no
continued you would just come into it
you wouldn't give a [ __ ] dick codger
here I'm gonna open
yeah he doesn't have an embarrassment
cell in his body we do not at all
super bad I've never seen you
embarrassed never ever I'm winning best
you got to literally scrape the skin out
of your ass or front of a bride do you
know what I was at first i swiping
skills good that destory you should be
so embarrassed of that we're crawling
I'll be here tomorrow you went like this
to wipe your ass that's like a
two-year-old move I didn't know the
chair look at the time Howard you told
her you educated it yeah I've been
somewhere now he still doesn't care it's
hard to change techniques it is yeah a
lot of muscle memory now to change her
to wipe your ass oh the change the
technique how do you pick your nose
don't change the technique like this so
now if I told you to freaking pick girls
with thumbs weird isn't it no cuz then
I'm like oh [ __ ] cool it's actually her
well maybe you don't have muscle memory
like I guess so this police officer he's
from Houston Texas 33 years old he's
been on the force for nine years he is
also on the SWAT team oh [ __ ] wow so
he's against it as [ __ ] yeah so
he asked an 18 year-old oh [ __ ] him
after he pulled her over for speeding he
doesn't know she's 18 [ __ ] him anyway
because you haven't discovered by Sentai
maybe he doesn't do math that bad
or he knows that she illegal so he
doesn't break the law so then he so he
pulled her over for speeding and an
expired registration this girl down he's
in the SWAT team and she didn't send a
dude that's like the special forces of
the police office and I am sure so what
they're saying is like roughly about an
hour after the traffic stop the officer
contacted the team through social media
through her social media and uh and sent
text messages also stupid
offering the change of tickets to
warnings if she sent him news oh that's
funny because I keep on hearing from
officers that once they write it they
can't change it and that's the reason
why they can't help you I hear that from
me you're mean I know that some [ __ ]
officers when there is a I rewrote it so
sorry man you [ __ ] lying [ __ ] [ __ ]
you all I had to do is show a little bit
Oh ma'am
can't wait to I get another ticket that
sounds weird I know I know you could
change it because we did a story on JK
news about this cop that didn't get no
titty pictures so he didn't get to
change the ticket but he offered her to
take the ticket maybe he was lying
mm-hmm maybe he can't even change it
still get stolen apologies he [ __ ] up
he was going to be like I can write you
this ticket but kind of see a little
titty maybe you couldn't because you
know how like the cop cars are
constantly recording the audio oh no
wait till afterwards yes because that's
what he uses thought oh you're smart -
well he's stupid this is people - yes
sir business this team she approached
the police department and let them know
about would have and do just mine so
they started an investigation they
opened up a case and they do report that
he's still employed but that he has been
pulled off of patrolling that he's not
patrolling anymore SWAT patrols that's
crazy
no because he's also like you know the
traffic traffic cop because he gave her
meaning to push on another distance
maybe he's a part-time SWAT yeah and so
they're saying that he has not been
criminally charged in the case but that
they won't further comment because it is
still ongoing but what law did he breaks
X portion extortion oh yeah and so what
they're saying is like the reason why
they wanted to report this story out to
the media is to see if they're other
women that can come forward that has
been extorted by I feel the big deal is
I'm gonna get extorted all day long I
guess I forgot the part where you said
I'll change your ticket I see it as a
yeah she has an opportunity to get out
of a ticket
yep I don't wanna Annie I want a clean
driving record [ __ ] up though no no he
it's our way it's not like it's no no
but it's it's not like he's like hey if
you don't show me a titty I'm gonna go
beat up the parents there's nothing
negative you don't leave any more the
positive ions for the positive he's just
saying hey there's an opportunity here
if you want to take it that's fine but
if you don't do it no you're assuming
that because they didn't even go that
far as soon as she got that she went to
the police no his his pitch was show me
a titty and I'll make it a warning that
was his pitch yeah but we don't know
what he would have said if she said no
so
just because the the outcome was
positive you think it's something I wish
it would happen to me I don't think it's
okay for her it's okay if you want it
that's the that's the debt the whole
moral here just the fact that he's
abusing his power it's still okay you
see it as abuse I see it as opportunity
yo he up hold a lot I think it's wrong
because she didn't want that if any cop
is out then you pull me over it's right
for me I just don't like the fact that
cops that a cop would do that for
personal gain trying to help society
exact trying to help this dick
that's not what he's supposed to be
doing as a cop now if you want to do
that as Steve the [ __ ] boy speed the
[ __ ] boy to do whatever he wants but
you're doing it that's right this isn't
Thailand we got to uphold the law here
in the US of A she was going on in
Thailand they take bribe I was a
starstruck with the SWAT dick so I was
like I'll do anything for you mr. Austin
and that's why you were born a man and
if you can get me out of a ticket
boom how I feel so bad for the cop if
you would like City probably go she was
fine and she was stood out her titties
all [ __ ] up like god damn I got your
[ __ ] Jetsons great tell your son all
these I got movie titties or something
anything isn't in you know just like
bread mold or some [ __ ] they pull down I
don't have a mustache yeah what if she
had like well it's instead we got like
90% aerial and seven hairs coming out of
it oh yeah baby city
I gotta give them a one plus I'll be
like Oh check this out I'll show you one
nipple right but you got to let me come
on a ride-along
and you gotta let me catch bad guys with
you so then would you actually send a
picture of your nipple or would you get
like a stock photo or like somebody
else's nipple online I'll send my own I
will send you my titties get some stock
photos get some amateur porn send it out
BAM there you go thanks for watching
just kidding news guys don't forget to
comment down below we want to hear what
you say only if it's positive remember
that to watch more videos go up here
baby
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]